guys Thurs night football not a great
first three quarters and I was getting
ready to call it and the fourth quarter
is pretty good the Saints made this
wonky comeback and they were right in it
and olavi didn't run a route and car was
getting upset but then they had a chance
uh here it is you know sometimes when
you watch a game like oh he should have
had that he should have had that like
catches that you know civilians like us
couldn't make in a million years but a
professional should have I've watched
this play like 10 times now Foster Moro
tight end for the
should he have had that this unfortunate
it is should
he I first thought man he had that his
hands were on it pretty clear that he
had a good shot at the ball oh great
play call Great the right decision right
spot great it seems like a great pet I'm
going to watch it again should he have
had
this
yes it's a little deep and a little it
hit his hands hit his hands this I mean
that no that's that's a catch he had
room on the back side too if he had to
go to the ground it's not a great pass
his arms aren even fully extended yeah
yep he put the pass where only his guy
can get it which is a big phrase he like
to use yep no you should have had that
that's like when you think you're going
to get hit footsteps of third yeah
alligator arm yeah it's magnified by a
thousand when there's 25 seconds left in
the game to tie the game I give credit
to 30 for breaking this play up right
he's like oh he saw that dude and he was
like yeah that peripheral was scary
yes about to crush so we're agreeing
that he should have had it okay I wasn't
sure 100% should have had it for sure I
just love when a Defender celebrates not
on that play but someone drops
theall I got beat for this it would have
been a touchdown they're losing 2416 but
they're like uh-uh uh-uh he dropped it
you did nothing you did nothing to stop
that yep in the NFL you catch that yeah
right Saints got hosed on a bad Pi call
earlier though that would have changed
the game sure
yeah that was tough good game turned out
to be a decent game